Vladimir Putin no es un político cualquiera:
es el personaje perfecto para una película
de espías.
Y la historia de hoy tiene mucho de película
Hoy vamos a hablar de un enfrentamiento entre
Rusia, Alemania y Estados Unidos, un megaprojekt
millonario y una persona, Alexei Navalny,
que puede dar al traste con toda la política
energética de un país tan importante como
Alemania ¿Estáis listos?
Pues vamos con el vídeo.
Seguro que muchos os habréis hecho esta pregunta
alguna vez ¿Cuánto poder real tiene Rusia?
Pensad que hablamos de uno de los países
más grandes del mundo... pero que tiene un
PIB más pequeño que el de Italia.
Así que ¿Por qué Rusia es tan importante?
Una de las razones es el gas natural.
Atentos a este mapa.
En este mapa podéis ver como media Europa
depende del gas ruso.
Prácticamente toda centro europa se ha acostumbrado
a comprar casi todo su gas a su vecino del
Este: está cerca y es barato.
Esto incluye, por supuesto, a Alemania, que
depende en un 60% del gas ruso.
Durante años, la Unión Europea ha estado
buscando alternativas para diversificar el
gas.
Sin embargo, si nos atenemos a los hechos,
la tendencia es clara: Alemania quiere depende
aún más de Rusia.
NordStream 2 completará el primero de sus
dos ramales tan pronto en Junio (de 2021)
Os presento el Nord Stream 2: un gasoducto
que conecta directamente Rusia con Alemania.
Con esta tubería gigantesca, Alemania podrá
garantizar el suministro de gas ruso sin ningún
problema.
El proyecto ha costado 9.500 millones de euros.
Y está a punto de terminarse...
La duda es ¿De verdad Alemania va a conseguir
acabar el Nord Stream 2?
Pues atentos, porque todo este proyecto está
desencadenando una disputa seria.
Una disputa entre Alemania y Estados Unidos.
Y, en buena medida, podemos decir que este
proyecto podría irse al traste por este señor
que veis en pantalla.
Alexey Navalny, el opositor contra Putin más
famoso de toda Rusia.
Este hombre supone toda una amenaza para Putin.
Tanto es así que en verano de 2020 le envenenaron
con el famoso NOVICHOK.
Si seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo,
ya sabéis que el NOVICHOK es un veneno inventado
en tiempos de la Unión Soviética.
Por supuesto, Navalny no es el responsable
principal de esta historia ni mucho menos.
Pero claramente su intento de asesinato ha
sido un catalizador.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero cuánto poder tiene
Navalny?
¿Por qué Alemania tiene tanto interés en
comprar gas a Rusia?
¿Y por qué Estados Unidos quiere impedirlo?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
LA CARA B DE LA DESNUCLEARIZACIÓN
Si hay un país anti nuclear por antonomasia,
ese es Alemania.
De hecho, uno de los partidos más importantes
en este país son los “verdes”, que se
fundaron para pedir el cierre de las centrales
nucleares.
Décadas después de su nacimiento, podemos
decir que han conseguido salirse con la suya.
En pocos años, Alemania ha cerrado casi todos
sus reactores.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el año 2002,
la energía nuclear suponía el 19% del mix
energético de Alemania.
Hoy en día, en el año 2021, está en el
3% y el plan es llegar al 0% lo antes posible.
Sin embargo, Alemania también es el mayor
consumidor de energía de toda Europa.
Así que, al prescindir de la nuclear, Alemania
tiene que producir más energía con otras
fuentes ¿De qué fuentes hablamos?
Pues atentos a este gráfico.
GRÁFICO FUENTES ENERGÉTICAS ALEMANAS
“El coste del ´Nucleares no gracias´:
mix energético en Alemania (2002-2020)”
Como veis, Alemania cada vez tiene más energías
verdes.
Pero todavía no se puede depender al 100%
de las energías verdes.
Almacenar energía es muy caro.
Y un molinillo eólico o un panel solar sólo
producen energía cuando hay viento o hay
Sol ¿Qué otras alternativas hay?
La más sencilla es el carbón.
Pero también es la más contaminante que
existe.
Así que ¿Cuál es la única alternativa
que nos queda?
¡Exacto!
El gas natural.
Podríamos decir que el gas natural es la
fuente de energía menos contaminante dentro
de las energías contaminantes.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el carbón expulsa
a la atmósfera 820 toneladas de gas de efecto
invernadero por cada Gigawatio de energía
producido.
El petróleo está en unos 720 toneladas.
El gas, sin embargo, está en 420 toneladas:
es decir, contamina la mitad que el carbón.
En otras palabras: podríamos decir que, en
el mundo de hoy, el gas es el nuevo petróleo.
Y Alemania es la prueba de ello: en 1990,
producían 40.000 gigawatios de energía por
gas.
En 2020 producían más de 94.000 gigawatios.
Es cierto que, en términos relativos, el
gas representa un porcentaje menor en el mix.
Pero la demanda de energía de Alemania aumenta
año tras año.
Para que os hagáis una idea, a día de hoy,
Alemania consume 90 BCMs de gas al año (es
decir, 90.000 millones de metros cúbicos
de gas al año).
Pues bien, se estima que, en 2034 será más
de 110 BCMs.
En otras palabras: Alemania necesita cada
vez más gas.
La pregunta es ¿Cómo se compra el gas?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
DESDE RUSIA CON AMOR
El gas natural viaja de dos formas distintas:
por tubería a través de gasoductos o en
barco, con la tecnología del Gas Natural
Licuado.
En este caso, el gas se convierte en líquido,
se transporta cómodamente y se lleva al país
de destino.
Una vez ahí, el gas licuado se procesa en
una planta para convertirlo, de nuevo, en
un gas.
El problema con esta tecnología es que es
cara y requiere de tener al menos una de esas
plantas para procesar el gas.
Y diréis ¿Tiene Alemania alguna planta de
estas?
Pues, por el momento, no.
Es cierto que hay proyectos para construir
una... pero, por el momento, todo el gas viene
por gasoductos.
Y el 60% de ese gas viene de Rusia ¡Y ojo
porque no son los únicos que compran gas
a este país!
Atentos a este mapa.
Como veis, otros países como Finlandia o
Rumanía, dependen en un 100% del gas ruso
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos!
¿Y dónde está el problema?
¡Ya están otra vez los de VisualPolitik
con su odio visceral hacia Rusia!
¿Acaso no compramos gas y petróleo a países
mucho más autoritarios?
Pues sí, tenéis razón.
Putin no es, ni de lejos, el mayor de los
tiranos que vende recursos naturales al resto
del mundo.
Pero también tenemos que reconocer una cosa:
Putin está dispuesto a usar su gas como un
arma política.
Es más, no sería la primera vez que lo hace.
Por ejemplo, en el año 2006, cortó el gas
que iba para Ucrania por una disputa política.
3 años más tarde, volvió a hacerlo y esta
vez, el corte también afectó a Alemania.
Y diréis ¿Por qué?
¿Qué tiene que ver Ucrania con Alemania?
Pues atentos a este otro mapa.
En este mapa podéis ver los gasoductos por
donde va el gas ruso que compra Alemania.
Si os fijáis, hasta 2011, casi todo ese gas
pasaba por Ucrania o por Bielorrusia.
En otras palabras, que si los ucranianos se
quedan sin gas, los alemanes también.
Así que ¿Cuál es la solución más pragmática?
Pues muy sencillo: construir un gasoducto
que conecte directamente Rusia con Alemania.
Una tubería que cruce el Báltico.
Pues bien, ese fue el proyecto Nord Stream
1, que se terminó de construir en 2012.
Sin embargo, Alemania necesita aún más gas.
Y no quiere volver a utilizar los gasoductos
que pasan por Ucrania.
Y así es como, de los creadores de Nord Stream
1 llegó...
¡Nord Stream 2!
¡La venganza!
Y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos ¿Y dónde
está el problema?
A fin de cuentas: no cambia nada.
Nos guste o no, Rusia ya vendía gas Ruso
a Europa.
Lo hacía antes del Nord Stream 1, y antes
del Nord Stream 2.
La única diferencia era por dónde viajaba
el gas.
Pues sí, tenéis razón.
Pero hay una víctima clara en esta historia:
Ucrania.
Pensadlo bien: si Rusia puede enviar su gas
sin pasar por Ucrania, podrían cortarles
el suministro sin problemas.
De un día para otro, Ucrania estaría a merced
de Rusia.
Y todo esto explica por qué los primeros
países en levantar la voz de alarma fueron
todas las repúblicas ex comunistas.
Siete países de la Unión Europea se oponen
al Nord Stream
Estos siete países incluyen Polonia, República
Checa, los bálticos y, en general, todos
los países que pertenecieron a la órbita
soviética.
Y entonces es cuando Angela Merkel dijo (((TONO
SARCÁSTICO))) “uuuhh ¡Mira cómo tiemblo!
Los países ex comunistas se enfrentan a mí!
¡Anda iros a vuestra casa y dejadme en paz!”
Y así es como en 2015, la rusa GAZPROM comenzó
la construcción del gasoducto.
De repente, el mar Báltico se volvió a llenar
de barcos con grúas, diseñados para poder
desplegar los tramos de tubería que van por
el mar.
Hablamos de uno de los proyectos de ingeniería
más fascinantes que se pueden ver.
Un proyecto que ya ha costado más de 9.500
millones de euros.
Parecía que nadie podría pararlo.
Y entonces es cuando llega el siguiente actor
de nuestra historia.
LA PRESIÓN DE ESTADOS UNIDOS
Estados Unidos y Alemania siempre han sido
grandes aliados.
Y esto no se debe únicamente a que ambos
son parte de la OTAN.
Mientras Francia ha dado la espalda a Estados
Unidos en muchos frentes como, por ejemplo,
la Guerra de Iraq, Alemania siempre ha ido
de la mano de Estados Unidos en política
exterior.
Y por eso esta noticia es tan sorprendente.
Nord Stream 2: Trump aprueba sanciones en
el oleoducto ruso
¡Y ya sé lo que pensará alguno!
¡Esto sería una bravuconada más de Donald
Trump!
¿Verdad?
Pues nada de eso.
De hecho, estas sanciones fueron aprobadas
en el congreso tanto por demócratas como
por republicanos.
Hay muchas razones por las cuales Estados
Unidos quiere evitar a toda costa que se construya
este oleoducto.
La primera es geopolítica pura y dura: les
interesa proteger a Ucrania, que es un país
aliado, y no les interesa que Rusia tenga
tanto poder.
La segunda es económica: Estados Unidos quiere
vender su gas natural licuado a Europa.
Y todo esto explica que estas primeras sanciones
fueran suficiente como para que algunas empresas
abandonaran el proyecto.
Ya en 2019, Allseas, que es una empresa suiza
de construcción de oleoductos en alta mar,
abandonó el Nordstream 2 para evitar sanciones.
Sin embargo, por el momento, ninguna empresa
había recibido un castigo económico real.
Cierto, Estados Unidos aprobó la posibilidad
de imponer sanciones económicas a todas las
empresas envueltas en este proyecto.
Pero, hasta ese momento, no existía una oposición
tan fiera contra este oleoducto.
SIn embargo, todo cambió en verano de 2020.
Científicos suecos y franceses confirman
que Navalny fue envenenado con Novichok
De nuevo: Alexei Navalny es quizás el mayor
enemigo político de Vladimir Putin.
El novichok es un potentísimo veneno utilizado,
principalmente, por los espías rusos.
Todo apunta a que este hombre ha sido envenenado
por gente cercana a Putin.
Y, aunque Navalny ha sobrevivido y ha recibido
tratamiento en un hospital alemán, esta noticia
lo cambia todo.
De repente, Francia, que no tenía una postura
clara con respecto al Nord Stream 2, ha pasado
al club de los países que se oponen.
Antes, era una cuestión de geopolítica pura
y dura.
Ahora, también es una cuestión de ética.
Podría verse como una forma de castigar a
Putin por intentar asesinar a sus opositores
políticos.
De igual forma que el asesinato de Kashoggi
ha dado al traste con muchos de los grandes
proyectos de Bin Salman, en Arabia Saudita,
el intento de asesinato de Navalny podría
dar al traste con el gran proyecto de Vladimir
Putin.
Para que os hagáis una idea, una de las últimas
medidas de Trump antes de dejar la Casa Blanca
fueron nuevas sanciones económicas para frenar
el proyecto.
En el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo,
más de 18 empresas han decidido abandonar
el proyecto.
Y la pregunta: la gran pregunta que os estaréis
haciendo ahora es ¿Y qué va a hacer Joe
Biden?
En principio, Biden está en contra del oleoducto.
Pero, por otro lado, tampoco quiere enfrentarse
a Alemania.
Así que ¿Cuál es su respuesta?
Pues nada más y nada menos que...
¡Ponerse de perfil!
Atentos.
Estados Unidos sanciona a un buque ruso en
la construcción del oleoducto Nord Stream
2, en el mar Báltico
En otras palabras: Biden ha dicho que mantendrá
las sanciones de Trump...
¡Pero sólo para empresas rusas!
El buque ruso en cuestión se llama FORTUNA
y es uno de esos barcos constructores de los
que os hablaba antes.
Un barco con enormes grúas que pueden desplegar
todos los tramos de tubería en alta mar.
Pues bien, tanto ese buque como todos los
demás que le ayuden a construir el oleoducto
recibirán sanciones económicas.
Y diréis ¿Son suficientes estas medidas
para frenar el proyecto?
En principio, todo apunta a que no.
De hecho, días después de que se anunciaran
estas sanciones contra Fortuna, el buque volvió
al trabajo como si nada hubiera pasado.
En el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo,
sólo faltan por construir 148 kilómetros...
de los 1230 kilómetros que tendría en total.
En otras palabras, que parece casi imposible
que estas sanciones tan tímidas vayan a acabar
con el proyecto.
No obstante, en Washington, los republicanos
están dispuestos a dar la batalla.
(Ted) Cruz pospone el nombramiento de Biden
de Burns como director de la CIA por el oleoducto
Nord Stream 2
Os prometí una historia de espías y aquí
la tenéis.
Ted Cruz y otros senadores republicanos se
han plantado.
Han dicho que no aprobarán el nombramiento
del nuevo director de la CIA... hasta que
Biden no apruebe sanciones más duras.
Y, para que las sanciones fueran efectivas,
tendrían que afectar también a empresas
alemanas.
No olvidéis que, si todo va según lo previsto,
este mismo verano se habrá terminado casi
todo el oleoducto.
Es decir, que si realmente quieren frenarlo,
tendrán que tomar medidas drásticas.
Y sí, eso incluiría sancionar a uno de sus
aliados más importantes.
Puede que esto parezca una historia menor,
pero realmente hablamos de uno de los grandes
dilemas de Europa.
Por un lado, tanto Alemania como toda la región
han disfrutado durante décadas de un gas
natural barato.
El nordstream 2 ayudaría a que la industria
europea fuera más competitiva.
Por el otro lado, supondría una amenaza para
Ucrania: un país de 44 millones de habitantes
que lleva años en una crisis terrible, en
parte, por sus malas relaciones con Rusia.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Creéis que el Nord Stream 2 es una buena
idea?
¿Pensáis que se terminará de construir
o, tal vez, Estados Unidos va a ser capaz
de frenarlo?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí, en
VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos al canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.